now I would like to ignore to Blair
Kaufman my friend who will be moderating
the first panel which is called the
future of the library Blair in addition
to his budding acting role as you saw in
the movie is the law librarian and a
professor of law at Yale Law School he's
an all-around wonderful person he's a
member of the administration of Yale Law
School and he's also a faculty fellow of
the Yale information society project so
before I turn it over to Blair I would
just like to thank you one more time for
joining us today and I hope you enjoy
this symposium thank you very much
Thank You Laura and thank all of my
friends and colleagues in the
information society project for pulling
this conference together and thank all
of you for coming my job is moderator is
to keep everybody on time that's my
primary job and so we're going to limit
each speaker to 12 minutes we have two
panels of speakers 12 minutes each and
then we'll break so we can have a
conversation with you and then we're
gonna have two more speakers and a break
with more conversation with you 12
minutes may seem like a short period of
time but actually it's so much longer
than 140 characters and these guys are
used to doing 140 characters so 12
minutes is like doing a huge paper I so
I'm going to try to keep my own remarks
very very short to just a few tweets
worth so let me tell you what we think
library 2.0 is it can mean different
things to different people
if library 2.0 is corresponds to web 2.0
we really think about social networking
and how social networking technologies
might be used in a library context and
as you saw in that video we're thinking
of all sorts of innovative ways that we
can employ social networking in the
library setting so we use it in our
information discovery tools they used to
be our online catalog what use it which
used to be our print card catalogs so
our information discovery tool allows
users to rank information resources
review information resources to add tags
to information resources and make the
information discovery tool more powerful
by harnessing the power of the network
we're using the social web technologies
to connect with our users and a number
of really cool and interesting ways so
we have a presence on Facebook I hope
that those of you on Facebook are all
fans of the Yale Law Library if you're
not sign up and be a fan
most of our librarians especially the
reference librarians are on Facebook a
lot of our librarians tweet we're a
Meebo and a host of other technologies
are being used to connect users and
we're thinking about how web 2.0
technologies can be used to generate
user content by using wiki technologies
and so on so there's that but actually
we're thinking here of library 2.0 is
something much broader we're thinking
about what is the role of a library in a
digital world if a library's traditional
role is to collect preserve and make
available information resources what
does that mean when we move from a
digital from a print environment to a
largely digital environment when instead
of purchasing materials were licensing
materials what does that mean for access
to our users what does that do to the
first sale doctrine what is our
responsibility which our concerns be
about digital raat we've heard a lot
about digital rot lately when what
happened what should we be concerned
about national catastrophes like Katrina
like wars like how are we going to
preserve for future generation of users
our cultural heritage if we're in this
digital world and what is the library's
responsibility in the preservation
context do we have a responsibility to
preserve our web pages do we have a
responsibility to preserve web pages
create
in our institution we have a
responsibility to preserve web pages
created by family members do we have a
responsibility to preserve blogs library
blogs faculty members bulk balkanization
when I first met John Palfrey the first
thing he asked me was what is the Yale
Law Library doing to preserve the email
correspondence for the historical
deanship of Harold Koh I said wow so
those are just a few of the issues that
arise in this library 2.0 contacts and
with that I'm going to turn it over to
my panel of speakers who will get a
little bit more into the various issues
and so the way we're going to proceed is
I first have Josh Greenberg who is the
technical internet guru at New York
Public Library and Josh is going to give
a general overview of library 2.0 issues
and what with examples of what's come up
in the New York Public Library context
we're then going to move on to my
colleague John Palfrey from the Harvard
Law Library who is the author of born
digital and he's going to tell us a
little bit about what we can expect from
this new generation of library users
that have grown up in an entirely
digital context and how that might be
driving libraries and the kinds of
services and information resources that
we provide so then well the 12 minutes
12 minutes my job is to keep them on
time and I'm just kind of pull them down
after 12 minutes and then up will allow
a question and answer period for you
guys and I again we're gonna hold you to
time to you just have about 15 minutes
for a question and answer session but
you know you can do it in 140 characters
or less write each question and then
we'll go back to the second half of the
panel we get animal walpert it was the
university librarian at MIT and also is
the director of the MIT press since the
neck unique vantage point she can tell
us a little bit about the future of the
book and the future of scholarly
communication and lastly we have my
colleague from the internet
Society project Charles Cronin and
Charles is going to talk a little bit
about how digitization may be changing
the landscape for libraries big and
small how it may or may not be and it
will close up and we'll have another
question and answer period after that
and that's how the program will proceed
so with that I'll turn it over to Josh
okay this volume alright I'm Josh
Greenberg I'm the director of digital
strategy and scholarship at the New York
Public Library where we're really in the
thick of this you're not believe this so
what I wanted to do today was was open
things up by telling you a story
and it's a story about a librarian named
Jessica pig's ax I got to know Jessica
shortly after I arrived at the New York
Public Library which was shortly after
she arrived as well
she's a reference librarian in the
general reference division of the New
York Public Library which is in which is
on the third the lofty third floor of
the big building with the Lions on 42nd
Street in New York which looks like this
today there are librarians behind a desk
and you can go up to them and ask them
questions and they will help you find
things this is very similar to the way
things have worked for about a hundred
years in that building what's remarkable
is actually if you notice here sort of
right in the center there are two brass
pneumatic tubes this is actually how
books are requested at the library you
go you file the form you put it into
this pneumatic tube it shoots down into
the bowels of the stacks and they pull
the books out for you so there's very
much this in-person mediation in this
this in-person role for for librarians
in the general reference division so
shortly after I got to NYPL we started
talking about about how do we get what's
the right role for library staff in the
online environment we talk a lot about
digitizing collections I got a lot of
pushback about saying this but to be
provocative I would say what do we how
do we digitize librarians there's
immense knowledge and expertise invested
in librarians and librarianship as a
profession how does that map into the
digital context particularly as we're at
a point when we're talking more about
social interaction online on one hand
there is there's live chat there's live
reference etc we also started a
different
X
Behrman twitch was blogging and blogging
not just as a g-wiz this is a trendy
shiny thing to do but blogging as a way
of externalizing knowledge in discrete
chunks and putting it out in a way that
could be discovered crawled aggregated
rolled into search results and really
worked into the experience of the
catalog and NYPL org in general so
really is a way to create a voice and
for an exposed staff online right now
we've got about 50 is the tag cloud of
the the most popular subject headings on
these blog posts as you'd expect
librarians really enjoy tagging and
categorizing their posts we we've got
about 50 librarians and curators drawn
from across the the library engaged in
this you know you can see just a brief
overview here so jessica was one of the
first Jessica started by writing about
knitting and writing about her first
post was about silk mittens and about a
new knitting stitch that she'd picked up
from a book in the collections she moved
on to write about to write about book
art culture and talked about the the
Center for Book Arts and a couple of
particular art books in the collection
someone might want to look at moved on
to talk about
excuse me talk about quilting a bit
stamping etc she basically very quickly
developed a sort of portfolio of
interests very much self-selected around
the general area of handmade culture
craft culture etc and its representation
in the collections of the New York
Public Library this was not her explicit
this was not in her job description this
was not in her her official this isn't
why she wasn't hired because she had
that expertise but when we gave her an
opportunity she very quickly started to
develop a really strong engagement with
this topic which is something she was
passionate about
as you'd expect she as she started to do
this she started to get develop an
audience an audience that began to
engage with her about not just the stuff
she was writing but suggesting other
materials suggesting other topics and
and actually starting to engage in a
real discussion so we sort of just did
this we put this out there and started
experimenting for the first nine months
or so this blog was out there it wasn't
linked off the homepage it was very kind
of viral word-of-mouth it's at NYPL dot
org slash blog if you're interested in
looking that's the sort of meta blog and
it can be sliced by author or by topic
and it's been up and running for about a
year and a half now
and it's actually gonna be a feature
much more prominently in a redesign of
NYPL org that's about to go live in a
couple months so Jessica had started it
started really building a voice and an
audience online standard sort of you
know web 2.0 kind of story
one of the people who she connected with
was a woman named Grace bonny who runs a
site called design sponge design sponge
as a community of enthusiasts around
design culture and craft culture roughly
a hundred thousand people I think read
design sponge a month and so she got in
touch with Jessica said hey I think what
you're doing is fantastic I love the
library could we do something together
so we had a meeting we all step back and
we sat around a table and brainstormed
and thought about hey what could we do
that you know you know that could you
know get our peanut butter in her
chocolate and her chocolate in our
peanut butter and and you know come up
with something interesting so what we
did was we actually developed a web
video series we did a four part web
video series called design by the book
which was very much inspired by the fact
that we were all total reality TV
junkies and thought hey there's this
really interesting model if you take
some talented people you put them in a
context you have them make something you
get them inspired and you have them make
something so we thought this is what
people want people to do at the library
and grace was thinking hey I want to be
able to do really great stuff with neat
material so he did a four-part web video
series episode one introduced five
artists that five New York City area
artists that de grâce selected from her
community and there's a printmaker
glassblower a ceramicist
episode - brought them into the library
they were they were met by Jessica who
both introduced them to materials in the
collection that they were interested in
but also introduced them to other
library staff as well episode 3 they
went back and they made something in
Episode four they unveiled it and talked
about the process the video was on our
so was on design sponge it was on NYPL
org and was on youtube we also pushed it
out to iTunes number of different
distribution channels so that's
interesting we thought we'd push the
boundaries a little further and actually
see how many of these people are willing
to tangibly come into the library who
are watching the video we've all told we
figure they're probably bout 20,000
people who watch the video series online
so we held an event we actually did a
launch party for the last for the last
video at the library where the artists
brought their artwork unveiled them
where we actually had a reference desk
of sorts staffed by librarians to talk
with people who came and and we're
interested turns out that by putting the
word out two days before the event just
via design sponge in our own blog we had
about 400 people show up at the library
almost none of whom had been in that
building before really great community
really great outreach a lot of people
have shown up to the library since
because they were exposed to what the
library had there's a Flickr group a
couple people started that were people
who were inspired by that web series and
we're taking materials from the
collections I believe the the top there
are a couple Eastern European textile
patterns that inspired someone to do new
work somebody else took some materials
and did I forget the name of the process
but a photographic technique - prints of
them so one example one pilot project
and I want to just in a couple further
for the last couple minutes spin out a
couple of themes that I think are really
important and raise core issues we've
got to think about obviously
intellectual property there are others
today who are going to speak with much
more sophistication than I will about
intellectual property one point to make
is in the course of this project in the
course of blogging about the collections
and of course
everything else we we have a very
explicit pressure to steer people
towards public domain materials because
of the perceived risk in in working with
in exploring fair use of in copyright
materials because as we as we turn
towards increased licensing of
collections you know of contractual
restrictions you know it's very much a
sort of chilling effect in in in
practice to bigger points though one is
about the changing role of the library
as an institution and really as a
platform you know when the model of a
librarian behind the desk where you
approach them and ask them questions
doesn't really hold in the online
environment honestly in the same way as
the model of a library as a big stone
building a temple to knowledge that you
have to enter and play by its rules when
we shifted from a world defined by
scarcity of knowledge to one at least
defined by the perceived ubiquity of
knowledge the library can't simply sit
back on its haunches or or at least our
lions can't and and and wait for
everyone to come to them it requires a
much more proactive engagement and
honestly one that takes place largely on
third party platforms we leave our
building physical or virtual and we go
out into the world and we engage and
library work happens out there this one
project involved YouTube Flickr iTunes
design sponge I now have a standing by
weekly meeting with our counsels office
because of the tangled thicket of
different contracts we have to sign in
order to be able to go out and do
library work in the places where people
already are a second point about the
changing role of librarians themselves
so Jessica like a huge number of people
who work at the New York Public Library
is fascinating incredible person to sit
down and talk to and up till now the web
presence of the library has looked like
it has had a voice that looks like this
and as such as the web presence it's the
institutional presence it's an
institutional voice it's not an
idiosyncratic individual voice and that
doesn't really map into the online land
either one of the things we're really
trying to do is free and open up the the
myriad diverse voices of our of our
staff now this is interesting because it
winds up really really complicating the
professional identity of someone like
Jessica Pizza who is blending her
personal passion with her work at the
library and there's not a complete
overlap she has a blog at the library
she has her own blog there's not a
one-to-one match of posts some posts are
cross posted some simply are on her blog
some are simply on the library's blog
she has a Twitter feed and ypl also has
a Twitter feed we pick up some of her
tweets some of them just you know are
are for her audience we haven't really
dug into how how the general public
perceives her role in the role of others
like this in this environment it's worth
noting that when you google her name her
library blog is what shows up first
followed by followed by her personal one
so in order to do this we've had to
develop policies on proactive policies
on public internet communication to
really enable this kind of work one
point to notice we we proactively said
anyone who blogs at NYPL
obviously the the product is the the
work product is the product is the is
the property of the library as as work
so the library holds the rights but
we've automatically issued a
non-commercial license to the bloggers
to to take their work and and and bring
it out into the the world but there's a
lot to learn especially because over the
next few years we have a thousand I
can't say we have a thousand Jessica
pigs but we have a thousand professional
librarians and curators at New York
public and it's a real question of what
does it look like at that kind of scale
what the one example I talked about
today so I'm at time so I'll say thank
you
great
so John Palfrey lair thank you so much
and Josh what a great opening
presentation this is fun I suspect
everybody here now wants to meet Jessica
and probably hire her for their
libraries I know I do
Blair and Jack and Laura and others
thank you so much for the chance to be
here at this conference as always you
host a wonderful gathering and quite a
crowd you've assembled here when Blair
called me the other day to talk about
what we were to say on this panel it was
pretty clear that he was steering me
away from library type topics I realized
that when I sat down and was saying
she's the token woman on the panel I'm
the token non librarian I think or want
to be library and somebody posing as one
he kept saying why don't you talk about
your research talk about your book talk
about born-digital not anything to do
with libraries and I may thwart you and
talk a little about libraries but but
starting with with research so Josh
started us started us off thinking about
the role of the reference librarian and
curators and others and I wanted to back
up one step and and look at what the
changing patterns are of usage of some
of our patrons and I work in a law
library at Harvard Law School and the
patrons are obviously primarily our
current faculty and students and want to
touch on those two categories and then
end by coming back to the notion of the
collection because I'm not sure we can
talk about services without talking
about what in fact is the base of
knowledge from which we're working so
first off I spent the last few years
doing focus groups and interviews with
kids and the kids were ages about 13 to
22 most were in the northeast of the US
can talk about the methodology in
another setting but it was focus groups
and then in-depth interviews with some
we did similar methods in Europe in
Bahrain and the Gulf and in East Asia to
sort of get a grounding but most of
these are our kids be familiar to you
then what we were interested in mostly
was the information pattern and sort of
technological usage of kids we were
describing as digital natives these are
kids who meet three basic criteria
one is that they're born after about
1980 the second is they have access to
the technology so very importantly
recognizing that only about 1 billion
people on the planet have access to
these things out of the 6.6 billion or
so and maybe if you add cellphones you
get another 3 billion or so but
recognizing they're people who are on
the other side of that divide and the
other is recognizing that many of the
young people don't have the technical
skills that jessica has or that others
have and that they're even in rich
places like this there are kids who use
technology and less sophisticated places
so I'm talking about the the kids who
have the access were born at this point
in history and have good skills to serve
stories that came out of the the
research that I think speak to the role
of libraries and and libraries 2.0 the
first set of questions that we ask is
was about how they would go about coming
up with information on specific topics
so in the familiar way we host ourselves
as say a high school teacher asking them
to do a report on a topic they knew
little about the two examples I used in
us focus groups were the
spanish-american war which everybody
knew had happened but couldn't tell you
it was in the late nineteenth century
and secondly Lou Gehrig's disease you
know another example of something people
knew roughly what it was but not not
much more so he said what would you do
today how would you start this research
open-ended type of thing and a hundred
out of 100 kids we talked to said they
would find their way to one of these
some physical device they would open it
up or turn it on and they would open a
web browser 100 out of 100 complete then
they would look for Google they would
type in Google always Google never Yahoo
Ask Jeeves nothing else it was Google
and then almost a hundred percent said
they would type in Spanish - American
War enter right or Lou Gehrig's disease
enter this is the exact pattern that
everybody we talked to follow then they
would look at the search results right
they would look at the ten things that
came and again almost a hundred percent
of the kids would look for the Wikipedia
entry for spanish-american war or Lou
Gehrig's disease and then click on that
right that's where they start and again
we're talking about almost every single
person we talked to no matter where in
the globe it was only at that point that
there was some variation in what they
did so this was where I think this
participation gap the difference in
sophistication kicked in so on the one
hand you'd have some students who would
simply say oh great I'm done right they
would use the cut and paste function and
put it in their paper and turn it in
presumably these children or young
people didn't get good grades but they
were efficient right and this work and
if you press them about what Wikipedia
was they didn't have all that much
knowledge about where it came from where
the participatory nature whatever on the
other end of the spectrum were the kids
who didn't believe it at all the total
skeptics and their line was basically
one of my classmates was here three
minutes ago they introduced two false
facts to screw me up on my paper so I'm
not gonna believe this at all right that
was the far other end and of course
there were some kids roughly speaking in
the middle but it was plain that this
was the process that they were following
as an introduction the first way to get
into a topic then everybody described
the process of scrolling down to the
bottom of page looking for other sources
right if it were something where they
could get access to some other things
than they might start the process of
triangulation and so forth but that was
really a very consistent mode of getting
there the other thing we asked them
about their Wikipedia practices once
they were on this page was has anybody
ever edited a Wikipedia entry so let me
just try in this audience how many
people added it a Wikipedia entry good
number right now this is many much
higher percentage so in our group it was
you know a couple people one or two out
of 100 say the following question was
have you ever edited a Wikipedia entry
to make a substantive change so I hope
you have made a substantive change on
Wikipedia many many fewer that maybe a
third of the people who raised their
hands before
anavar example none of the kids zero
kids had ever made a substantive edit in
Wikipedia so query as to where this
Delta falls they were the OCD kids who
changed you know semicolons to periods
right they just couldn't stand to see
this thing in an unfixed way but the
notion that we we as Internet scholars
have that every kid is now going from
being consumer of information to creator
isn't there yet
right it's not exactly that we're in
this participatory culture or the one
that Jack Vulcan yet describes in terms
of cultural democracy we're headed there
but it's not the norm even for the most
sophisticated kids ok anecdote two out
of the research we asked them a lot
about how they got news and for
Meishan of the sort of up-to-date sort
and this was intuitive too we found
nobody basically who bought the New York
Times or the yel Daily News or the
Boston Globe or whatever it might be and
opened it in the morning and had a cup
of coffee and read it cover-to-cover
nobody basically write the same pattern
was true that they all basically got the
information more or less by some form of
grazing for it over the course of the
day so they would have one of these
little devices in some fashion they
would get headlines they would be online
they would be following what their
friends were doing on Facebook or
Twitter they were getting the
information through a very social
process that was step one step two was
that after grazing for the information
some of them were doing a deep dive some
of them wanted to go to the blog the
design blog for instance on that topic
and then that was fewer of the students
and then lastly the small group of them
also wanted them to provide some
feedback they wanted to blog it
themselves reblog it make a video about
it make a a slideshow so you had a
declining number of people doing this
the vast majority were just getting the
headline just the snippet some would
then dig into the richness of the
analysis and so forth and then some
would participate in the web 2.0 thing
but but it's a it's a subset and I
wouldn't press this also in the library
context which is over the course of the
last nine months at the Harvard Law
School Library we've introduced a number
of the things and in fact it many
predated me like me both that Camilla
Tubbs was talking about in here and as
we evaluate the web metrics many many
many many many more people still come to
the reference desk or talk to a
librarian in person then go to the Meebo
chat box right it's a great entree a few
students do that but it really is about
then that next in-person meeting so I
think one of the very important things
to note is we are in incredibly early
days in even how our most sophisticated
students are using these technologies
and we have to experiment in the meebo
kind of way and in the Facebook in the
youtubes kind of way and we should
absolutely be doing that at the margins
but we also need to be watching what's
working what's actually helping the
teaching and learning process for our
students how are they really learning
and where do they really need the help
this is a crucial thing for us to
continue to focus group
and talk to our students and to provide
a key guide secondly our faculty are
sort of a similar story in a way that
there's a split I think among our most
sophisticated users many who are
decrying sad about the disappearance of
the Prince books on the shelves and
wondering about this transition we're
making to a digital age and others who
are saying we're not going fast enough
some who are saying the practice and the
study of law is interdisciplinary and
where's the data I want the data that I
can crunch and put into my Law Review
article some are saying it's an
international field why are you so far
ahead with us materials and so less far
ahead with things in the stands for
instance which is something that some
people are studying there's a real
breadth I think in terms of the needs
and what what faculty are expecting we
did a experiment this fall with hiring
an empiricist a postdoc who spent half
of her time in our library she was so
overwhelmed with demand from both
faculty and students that it was clear
we could have filled up three or four or
five FTE is worth of support in our
library for empirical research support
figuring out how to access data how then
to process it and so forth this is
something obviously that even a few
years ago wouldn't have been so clearly
needed so I got the two minute sign
there and Blair I will try to keep to it
but I want to mention in addition to our
faculty and students and changing norms
it's important also to put in the frame
of the same services discussion this
notion of our collection what is our
collection what is it meant to be or
where will it go and I think one of the
things we have to do as librarians is to
do some vision here and define five or
10 years from now what do we want that
collection to look like where are we
simply providing access what are the
materials that are just going to be
shared basically looking at brewster and
Carl Malamud and others there's a
version of the law or whatever your
field is that's literally going to be
shared public domain material to which
we're going to point and our job is to
provide access sometimes license
sometimes unlicensed I hope more
unlicensed the hacking of pacer the
Steve Schultz is talking about files in
this category
there's on the other end of the category
which is the unique materials that we
have the materials from Harold COEs
deanship or balkanization
in Jack vulcans case where these are
unique materials that we have in our
Special Collections as well where what
we have to do is either render some of
those available into this Commons or
find other ways to share them digitize
them and so forth and then of course
there's the big mass in the middle which
is we're still gonna buy monographs
right people still want to read some
books and we need to figure out how are
we collecting in a way that's
collaborative how do we collect in a way
that we're sharing the responsibility of
preserving this knowledge in these
formats but it's that picture of an
ecosystem I think that we have yet to
develop I think we still have somewhat
old fashioned notions of who's
collecting what I know that at the
Harvard Law Library many people think
we're collecting a lot more than we are
and in an era in which we're cutting our
budget by 10%
that's cutting 1.4 million dollars out
of our budget there gonna be many fewer
things that we're buying in this coming
year and I think it's crucial that we
all sort of understand what we're doing
and what we're not doing and aim toward
an access to knowledge style system as
the Yale ISP has been urging us to do so
just by way of a wrapper on these these
topics I think they're urged me to talk
about libraries services what are the
services we're going to be talking about
and I think what's crucial here is to
recognize to some extent out of the the
literature in open source software Eric
Raymond urged us to think about the
cathedral and the bazaar this is a
familiar thing to us as techies and in a
way I think that's partly what's
happening here too which is yes we will
still have it's still a hybrid
environment there still will be
cathedrals in the sense of you know
temples to knowledge beautiful spaces
like the library here but there's also
the bazaar and I think increasingly our
young people and to some extent our
faculty are operating in the bazaar I
think we're very good at being the high
priests in the temple or the high
priests in the Cathedral I think we're
much less good at being the guides in
the bazaar who grabbed the students and
walk you through the bazaar and help you
against your worst instincts and help
you to the really good stuff and I think
that's the crucial thing we have to
figure out is while we're transitioning
from all Cathedral to some combination
of Cathedral and bazaar how do we do
that guide thing and figure out that we
know
some students are doing bad things when
they're learning we know some faculty
can't keep up with these resources how
do we bring everybody along and serve
our teaching and our scholarship mission
in the process so thanks so much
okay so now it's your turn please come
and ask questions we this is what this
is all about involving you in the
conversation as you're thinking about
how we're going to be dealing with more
and more bizarre users in the library
over the next decade let me just go for
that with with the first question but
there are microphones out here in the
center please come and and engage in the
conversation but my first question for
John while you're thinking about your
own questions is when we think about the
Harvard Law Library most of us think
about its superb collections that this
is an institution that truly has some of
the best law collections in the world
where do you how do you imagine the
Harvard Law Library ten years from now
what's going to distinguish the Harvard
Law Library and the way that its
collections now distinguish it today so
Blair thank you
this is of course a hugely dangerous
question as the physicist niels bohr
mentioned its prediction is dangerous
especially about the future and I think
in this particular case I could get
myself in a lot of trouble by answering
this question wrong it is it is the case
I should note that as we're making these
decisions about what to cut it's not
that much fun time to be a library
director right now we often ask what is
Yale doing so we pick up the phone call
call Fred and say are you guys cutting
this and is there like how much trouble
are we going to get in when those
reporters don't keep rolling in but know
much more seriously I think what is
going to distinguish great collections
is you know multi faceted so I think one
is to say again what are the unique
materials that we have in our historical
and special collections how were we
making those accessible so one way we're
making them accessible is digitizing
right we have this great collection of
materials on war crime
the Nuremberg papers and so forth we
need to make those in digital form and
make those into Brewster's Commons I
want to contribute to that
to some extent a second is the born
digital materials that our faculty are
coming up with today right so some
version of that is an open access policy
we as a Harvard Law School faculty voted
to commit to make all of our scholarship
available on an open access basis we're
pushing our journals to do the same
thing which is the Duke approach to that
and so if we're think that's a that's a
crucial step another we announced last
week a fellowship in honor of Yale's
Morris Cohen which is to give money to
young scholars who don't have research
budgets to come travel to the Harvard
Law School Library to do it and so forth
so I think that's that's kind of one one
piece of it and really is saying what is
it that we have that others don't and
how do we render that accessible but I
think there's also the piece that says
look on a preservation basis we as a
publisher Harvard University and MIT in
this case ought to take on the
preservation and the archiving role to
some extent for the stuff that we create
but we can't take on the archiving and
preservation role for everybody for
everything in all libraries I mean this
is where the rub is going to come in
which is stuff that's not in Brewster's
archive it's not something that we've
got and are preserving the stuff in the
middle that Elsevier or others are
publishing commercial publishers who is
archiving and keeping that and I think
the trick right there is to say we as
the Harvard Law Library need to be
non-exclusive about this we need to be
less competitive we need to be better
collaborators and say we're gonna do
some part of it but we're not going to
be on the hook for buying everything
we're gonna work with you and we're
gonna work with you and figure it out
and we're gonna create an ecosystem
that's reliable both for access and
preservation actually before the before
the question if I might seize the
opportunity for a moment and respond to
a point that was raised on Twitter that
I'd like to clarify there's a TR Bruce
in the back of the room awesome
tell me if I'm if I'm mentioning it or
if I'm twisting the the question but you
did raise the point about why you know I
raised this success story if it seemed
like the message was hey if we put stuff
online it brings people to the physical
library and that I want to make sure
that that's not the point that I that I
came across with
to me I think it's important we've had a
lot of discussion of the move to digital
and digital techniques I what I want to
try to do is start bringing into the
conversation the fact that our users
live in both physical and digital
environments and they modulate back and
forth between them in very sophisticated
ways so to me the reason that I've
brought up as the sort of you know the
the sort of apex of that project the
fact that we actually had 400 people
come into the the biggest room in the
New York Public Library who hadn't been
there before is more an indicator of a
community that was formed of a real
engagement when we talk about web 2.0
sites we often talk about the big
collection driven ones like YouTube or
Flickr we talk a lot about about you
know Facebook as a social thing I don't
think we talked quite enough about
meetup which is another example of an
incredibly influential site you know we
talk about online fundraising as lessons
to be drawn from the Dean and the Obama
campaign's but that notion of actual
like mobilization of physical people
doing physical things and engaging
particularly as you know like you we're
orienting more towards towards focusing
our resources on the rare and unique
archival materials that we have and
bringing people into physical engagement
with them where possible in addition to
the digital side I just wanted to kind
of nuance of my point a bit because I
didn't want people to walk away thinking
that to me the point is just getting
people into the physical building it's
clear to me that you're using your
BlackBerry Twitter app because I
couldn't get on Wi-Fi up here I think
they block the speaker's from I have a
quick question for Josh hi
sort of following up on that in terms of
the success stories that you've talked
about the morning what kind of
institutional challenges within my Pio
especially given the stature of that
institution challenges both culturally
within the institution and also now just
because of budget issues is digital
initiatives being reinforced because of
budgetary concerns or are they being
diminished because of budgetary concerns
thank you so on the on the latter point
first in terms of the
the impact of the current context on on
what we're trying to do I joined the
library just shy of two years ago as
part of an already underway process to
reorient and retool the New York Public
Library for a world in which people
interact with information increasingly
differently the library was built for
the 20th century and we're trying to
figure out how how do we reconfigure it
for the 21st which meant more investment
in digital and digital information more
investment in digital engagement etc at
the same time when last September in
October the sky fell a separate and
parallel trajectory of how do we simply
you know close a monster budget gap hit
us and we're doing the best we can to
kind of reconcile those two and make
sure we don't abandon the first in the
interests of of the second that's hard
work and in process I don't I think the
goal is to come out of the current
economic climate positioned well to to
engage going forward and not have to be
building from scratch you know two three
however many years from now when when
when you know the economy comes back on
the institutional challenges point one
of the things I highlighted that I'll
just I'll just emphasize it's that
tension between the individual voices of
the staff of staff and the public and
the institutional voice of the New York
Public Library that's a real challenge
and there are very different
perspectives we don't have total
consensus within the library right now
the best I can do is probe the edges do
pilots come up with places where even
for the the very you know traditional
you know voice of the institution folks
they can look at something like this and
say hey there's value here and maybe we
can learn from it and scale
appropriately I'm just wondering a
question for John Palfrey what are some
of the major hurdles that we need to be
trying to overcome in the direction of
the Duke model open open access to legal
scholarship soon
there are lots and lots of hurdles it's
hard to know where to begin exactly so
there are clearly a series of
institutional hurdles in terms of
adoption on a local level and then their
series of institutional hurdles that are
kind of more systemic of the
intellectual property variety and so
forth
so just describing the Harvard Law
School experience we took it to our
faculty as a vote and even before our
student journals even we're focused on
this issue we as a faculty force
forced the issue and said we want to do
we voted unanimously to make our own
scholarship open access the there hurdle
that we faced in that particular dynamic
really was serve an education one and
it's still ongoing I got a call
yesterday from a faculty member saying
oh my gosh a year ago we voted for this
thing I know I think it's a good idea
but wait a minute why did we do this
this is totally annoying why is it
annoying because she has to now go and
get a little addendum to fix the
intellectual property clause in the
journal agreements of which I think
bridges that sort of institutional
problem of people don't get it yet don't
get they understand why we're doing it
like the public good aspect is clear but
then how do you actually implement it
how do you make it real that's a big big
issue and we now have an office of
scholarly communication with multiple
FTE is trying to make it real but I
would say it's only a fraction of what
we're publishing right now is actually
going into the repository so I think
that's that's kind of the first one I
think the second one really is this
broader issue of a cycle that's
developed around publishing that we have
to break right I mean if you think about
it from the perspective of a law school
and followed a no-hitter on the sciences
and so forth we pay the faculty right to
create the work or the you know fellows
or whoever else we then pay the journals
to exist we prop them up financially and
help them print stuff and then we as the
library actually go ahead and buy that
stuff not only do we buy it from the
journals directly in print we buy it
from Mac from Lexus and you know Westlaw
and heinonline and others now we need
some intermediaries I'm not saying we
need to get rid of publishers but we
have a cycle that's
quite different than the the model that
I think we're getting to and at each of
those levels we need to have some kind
of change right the faculty have to
reorient ourselves to participating in
the Tom Bruce burst Brewster Kahle kind
of Commons the journals have to be on
board with a different revenue stream
for themselves and then we as libraries
have to rethink again our role for as
access providers and preservers of some
information and before we go all open
access we need to be darn sure that
people are preserving what's being
created too right so if we make it this
is the data what route problem we have
to get to a stable open digital format
and backwards compatibility now as other
things as well as a commitment on the
part of some of us to archive enough of
it that we know that we'll have as good
a system as before so it's a you know an
entire conference could be done on the
challenges of open access but I think
the best thing that could possibly
happen is that more schools pick up at
either the faculty mandate or do it
through libraries or do it through
journals but I think we have to stand up
and say this is collective action and
we're turning this into a collective
action opportunity not a collective
action problem libraries around the
country that go after that statement and
I think they came up in the context of a
lot of us work announced that we were
going to begin cutting our subscription
to print journals and so it was in order
to preserve access to those journals we
this was a good aspirational kind of a
document I think in retrospect neither
one of the mistakes was calling on
journalists deceased publishing in print
maybe they wait on that stuff
um this is a question for Josh your
comment was about trying to steer your
users and patrons more towards public
domain materials because my check my
paraphrasing you have concerns about the
risks around fair use and copyright can
you talk more about that let's see I
mean when you're actually on the ground
trying to do some sort of like you know
quasi guerilla style outreach thing like
like what we did where especially where
there are a lot of concerns and tensions
are on the institutional voice versus
versus individual things and where
you're at an institution that I like to
say you know turns like the the Queen
Mary if you're trying to trying to
trying to chart a different path you
know there's a lot of institutional
conservatism and there's there's been a
huge amount of back-and-forth even at
the basic level of okay what's a safe
video to put online what kind of checks
and gatekeeping do we have to have to
make sure that something that the
institution is comfortable putting
something as simple as a video file
online so for the design by the book
series not only did we make sure that
there were no camera shots of anything
that was that was was sort of under
copyright and we didn't scare the
artists that way we also got signed
releases from everybody that are
extremely comprehensive and I'm not
saying that that we we had to do this I
think the decision was we're pushing the
envelope in a number of other places so
maybe this is you know let's not bite
this off too because we actually want to
get this done and not have the counsel's
office who are great and who I'm working
with regularly and who serves a very
important function not have them bite
our heads off about this piece as well
and that's really just the the issue of
within an institution the the competing
voices that
and competing agendas that help to
define this kind of stuff just in
practice they respond just really
briefly I know this wasn't directed to
me but just as a intellectual property
lawyer I think it's crucial that we push
the boundaries on fair use so I actually
think this is a use it or lose it kind
of statute and we have to figure that
out and push it now if there is any ship
bigger than the Queen Mary I would use
that to invoke the image of mothership
Harvard right so is no doubt that this
is you know I get that this is hard I am
the counsel's office worst nightmare in
this respect to I understand I'm putting
you know things at risk by pushing it
but if we don't figure out what is fair
use in this context by these us by
people who are providing this for
knowledge and in the kind of semiotic
democracy cultural democracy gin Jack
Vulcans terms way I'm shame on us for
not pushing that and figuring it out and
if I could just just respond also
because I don't want to it's interesting
cuz normally I'm the to the barricades
person in conversations and I don't want
to come wrong I don't want to come
across as not because I because I am as
well and and I do actually have you know
I think we need to have skin in the game
in in doing this very much it's let me
just tell one one thirty second
thirty Seconds which was at that at that
event we had it turned out that we did a
Q&A with some of the artists the first
question was an artist from Brooklyn who
wanted to know wait so if I go to the
library I can actually you know use and
incorporate some of the material in my
artwork and it turned out that it was an
incredible teaching moment for 400
people to say yes absolutely we want you
to do that that's how these these
collections continue to live and breathe
and move on and it turned out that
actually the library is having a program
two weeks later which was on fair use
for artists which was you know
incredibly over attended so I think we
absolutely are pushing that boundary
I just wanted to we played it a little
safe in this context because we were
pushing other boundaries first
the questions we're going to move on